hey everybody welcome back to css3 in 30
days
today is day number 12 and we are going
to be playing around with something
called CSS variables there's also you
can call it custom properties but that's
not as exciting CSS variables especially
for developers and designers out there
who are familiar with variables in
languages like PHP or jQuery or even
using CSS preprocessor languages like
sass and less and s CSS where you use
variables it really extends the
functionality of CSS or whatever
programming language you're using that
are using the variables so in this case
we're just gonna be using plain vanilla
css3
but you do have access to something
called custom properties or aka CSS
variables so jump over here in our
browser we're just going to be coding a
couple simple boxes nothing crazy but
the neat thing about this everything
we're doing here from the measurements
to the colors are are used and created
or styled rather via custom properties
or CSS variables so why don't we just
jump in and get started so here in my
code editor I'm back with Adam hopefully
it behaves well we have day number 12
CSS variables go ahead and download that
folder open it up in your code editor
and then let's jump right back in here
in the index you're just gonna see the
usual that we've been using these past
12 days and just down here you're gonna
see in the section just two divs one
with the class of box and one with the
class of box box two and of course you
can go down to the final result and
check out how that's coded up in the
final CSS there are a lot of comments
and notes in here to help you understand
why we are doing certain things
explaining the custom properties and
everything like that but what we're
going to concern ourselves with is this
file sandbox dot CSS as usual and we're
going to get started
let's start off by selecting the sandbox
class and within there what we're going
to do is declare three different
variables or custom properties and the
way this works with custom properties in
CSS is the one you define and that
specific custom property within a
selector it is its scope is that
selector so if you wanted the these
variables to be accessible across the
entire website and all styles you would
use a selector like body or something
like a root is another selector the root
element of a tree representing the
document you can use those selectors if
you want these specific variables to be
accessible throughout the entire
document something like a color or a
font size or maybe branding specifically
branding colors but we're just going to
use in this case sandbox so all of the
variables are its scope is this selector
so the variables won't work if I am
trying to use those variables on
elements outside of sandbox so this is
how you start a selector sorry this is
how you start a variable you start out
with two dashes and then you name the
variable so I'm gonna say primary -
color and I'm gonna say orange red
another variable here I'm gonna say
secondary color - color that is hot pink
and then double - base - measurement 20
pixels so three variables it's not going
to do anything if I save this and check
it out in the browser it's not gonna
actually do anything because those
aren't actual Styles they're just
variables now let's go back down here
and let's access the variable like so so
I'm gonna select the sandbox and then
box so these are both of the boxes and
let's just first of all
text-align:center and now what we're
going to do is let's actually add one
more variable within sandbox box so now
this variable is only accessible within
this particular scope with inbox within
sandbox so you can't actually use it
outside of this selector or these
elements rather so I'm going to say
Double Dash text color it's going to be
f3f3f3
okay now here's how we access the
variables so I'm gonna say color and we
have to open it up with var and then
opening and closing parentheses and then
a semicolon of course and then all you
do here is just call the name of the
variable that you created double dash
and text color text - color now if I
save that and then go over to the
browser you're gonna see that you cannot
see the text and that's because it is
the same color as the background in this
case or pretty close and this is
centered so we know that that variable
is working let's continue and style the
background and we're going to save our
open closing variable or var double -
primary - color and let's go ahead and
say margin and whoops there we go and
I'm gonna say var this one's gonna be
base - measurement which as we know is
20 pixels so go ahead and save that
check it out in the browser now it's
doing something the background is that
primary color which is orange red and
the base measurement is of margin is 20
pixels it is working so this is nice so
now one other cool thing that you can do
with the measurements is you can
actually do math by using the calc
function so let me show you how to do
that height we're gonna say var and then
base measurement - - measurement but we
don't want to just leave it there let's
wrap this in calc
and then semicolon and we're gonna
calculate this but then we actually have
to perform a calculation so outside of
this so this is the first argument here
and then there's one more x we're gonna
say x 10 so we're gonna calculate the
VAR based measurement or the base
measurement times 10 and that should
equal excuse me 200 pixels and then I'm
gonna copy that and paste it I'm gonna
change this to width I want to be the
same because it is a box and then I want
the line height to in fact be the same
as well now if I save that I should have
perfect boxes head over to the browser
there we go all using the variables and
the CSS here let's check it out what
shows up so we've got box and then if we
look at the styles it actually is
showing up as var text color primary
color measurement it's actually showing
those variables it's not showing the
final calculated number in there at
least in this developer tools there and
so I find that pretty interesting now
let's do is go back to our code editor
and we're gonna do one a final thing
here if you scroll down beyond that
we're gonna say sandbox and then box 2
we want to make that color a box to
different background we've already set
up a variable for it var double dash
secondary dash color save that in the
browser we've got our orange red box
number 1 and our hot pink box number 2
the colors and the measurements are
calculated and created using custom
properties also known as CSS variables
that is exciting I hope that shed some
light and some insight on some cool
things that you could do with CSS
variables instead of having to go in and
create you know install preprocessors
and different CSS languages like sass
and less for certain projects that might
not be that necessary or too much work
maybe just a simple landing page and you
just want to get something out quickly
you can use CSS variables make sure you
check at the bottom of this page here
you can see the
ss3 styles how compatible they are with
major browsers if you click that it'll
take you to a page called can I use and
then you can type in something like CSS
variables custom properties it permits
the declaration and usage of cascading
variables and style sheets and you can
see here how compatible they are so with
IE 11 it's not supported oh well and
edge it looks like it's partial support
and full support here on 16 Firefox
fully supported Chrome fully supported
Safari Opera iOS Safari fully supported
Opera Mini not so much Android 56 yes
4.4 no and Chrome for Android so we're
pretty darn covered here so that's
pretty neat you can see up here the
percentage here so the global percentage
is about seventy seven point nine
percent compatible so you can rest
assured that you're pretty safe using
CSS variables also known as custom
properties I hope this lesson was
exciting for you and gave you some ideas
and quick hot tip if you want to get
access to all of these 30 lessons all at
once rather than waiting day by day
maybe you're ready to take on a
challenge and get everything all at once
all you got to do is pay five bucks you
get all the 30 days plus a full 30-day
membership to code college where you get
access to all of my coding courses ever
and just for five bucks and then after
that 30 days if you want to stay then
it's just 34 dollars a month afterwards
you can cancel at any time basically
it's a subscription-based model think
netflix for coding tutorials and if you
don't want to keep going then all you
got to do is cancel before that 30-day
window is up so once again all you got
to do is head to Brad husky dossier
slash gimme css3 there should be a link
up here on the screen go ahead and go
there you'll get the first month
membership of code college for five
bucks that'll get you all the 30 days of
these lessons plus every coding course
I've ever made and you can have a hey
Dave
and if you want to stick around then
it's just 34 bucks a month hope to see
you in there if not I'll see you
tomorrow for day number 13 bye now
[Music]